the kids could learn more about the
World by playing chess chess brings some
unique qualities it's about learning
self-discipline just learning something
about logic learning about your own
attitude and at the end of the day
learning about responsibility because
that's very important sense of
responsibility that's what is being
missed now all over the place and in
chess you have no one to rely on I mean
you you have no backup you make a good
move you win you make a bad move you
lose so that's a hard lesson you can
take from shares and that's why I'm a
great proponent of eventually installing
chess into the educational system we
could see chess in every classroom
worldwide because you don't need the
soccer field or tennis court for the
very little expense you can install
something that could help kids to
improve their performance in the general
curriculum so I would encourage anyone
to teach their kids playing chess thank
you